foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money John has
a new book coming out in just a couple
of weeks from tomorrow it comes out on
October the 3rd this uh recording as
you're hearing it right now is September
the 18th and today is the last day that
you can pre-order and get the e-book
early if you ordered a day you'll get
the ebook for free tomorrow that's
pretty cool John I didn't even know that
that's fantastic yeah it's pretty neat
nearly half the US population reports
that their lives are affected by anxiety
stress or burnout the book is building a
non-anxious life and he walks you
through the six daily choices to
recognize and break free from a life
spinning out of control the book is
already a huge success and it's not even
out yet the sales are huge because
there's a problem out there that's huge
that's right it's an absolute mess out
there it was it was good this past
weekend to connect with a live audience
and um
man they're feeling it you know just
real regular moms and dads and brothers
and sisters and aunts and uncles are
feeling it out there and so yeah it's a
mess yeah at the Smart conference this
last weekend John did the talk smoke
fire and freedom which has a lot of the
content of the book in it or some of the
content on the book in it and uh yeah
that audience was sitting on the edge of
their seats followed by Standing Ovation
so it's absolutely uh yeah it's touching
a nerve to say yes anxiety is real
yes there's a lot of things real in the
mental health space the statistics of
death and despair are huge and uh and
yet there's hope there's yeah there's in
this book is the road map and I think
that's missing a lot
um most of the solutions are
um
come pay us a whole bunch of money and
we'll we're going to try a bunch of
stuff over the next four weeks five
weeks six months and this is a um a
pretty consistent road map it's been
been around for a long long time I
didn't invent any of this stuff this is
as ancient as as time but um it also
incorporates the latest Neuroscience
which of course
that's just going to confirm what we've
known for generations and generations
but it's a road map it's a road map to
completely doing life differently now
the six choices that you can make daily
to um really prepare your your life for
when anxiety comes not if it comes then
you can handle it and it's not so
debilitating because anxiety is not a uh
it's not a disease right think of it
this way we've all agreed
um that we're gonna
brush our teeth twice a day so that if
there comes a moment when we have really
bad breath we probably have a tooth
infection we need to go get it checked
out but we just decided not have bad
breath everyday anxiety can be very in
Burnout and this distress stress stress
this way we've chosen to to construct
Our Lives
um man if you work on this stuff every
day over time it really straightens your
life out and then you know when
something sideways comes when you're
about to get fired when you lose your
job when your spouse is cheating on you
it sounds the alarms appropriately so
and then you can have a plan to go
forward there yeah and what's weird is
this I 45 years ago
I was in class in college
and the professor was talking about the
Advent of computers and how they were
going to change our lives and change
business and we were taking computer
classes with card readers we had to type
out the little cards you know thing I
mean that's how Antiquated it was right
but the professor said something that
has stuck with me ever since I I don't
even remember the guy's name but I
remember the statement he said more
information
is not necessarily going to be better oh
man how relevant is that how many people
do we meet that and you and I are in a
position people ask us
um
how many cups of coffee have you had
with somebody about 40 just make the
decision right yeah or how many times
how long have I spent on the computer
researching workout program but I have
more data I could just go to work out I
still don't do anything with it it's not
helping I've got more data I've got more
Connection in my hand that's not real
because Facebook friends aren't real
friends I've got more Connection in my
hand with this little magic wand I carry
around than anybody in history and yet
we're the most disconnected
so more connection doesn't equal more
connection that's so strange more
communication doesn't equal more
connection right there we go so I can
communicate with everybody all day long
but man I need to be in a room with
people but it's low quality
communication that's right I mean the
lowest possible quality communication
will be a text and we've heard that
we've heard the statistics next would be
a voice and the best quality
communication is in person because you
get tone body language eye movement you
get everything then and you can go oh
she's lying well and we all know that 70
to 90 of communication is non-verbal but
we took out all the non-verbal stuff and
which leaves us with you know 16 year
old that only knows how to do a breakup
on a text Dave I had a graduate student
come in one day crying and shaking and
handed me his phone and he had just been
served like you're getting papers today
he got divorced via text oh my God and
get this the my response is are you
gonna talk to her what are you doing
like why are you here and the response
was well we've got a zoom call set up
for Friday and I said
didn't say he's weak or I can also look
at the kid and say oh no Society he
don't have any skills yeah I mean he
lies he's telling him a lot that this is
that this is okay this is the way this
is the way to have a friend as a
Facebook friend this is the way to do a
breakup is on the text this is the thing
so this all these things create anxiety
is my point correct and uh so building a
non-anxious life does not mean you live
in a cave and you don't Embrace any
technology ever that is not what it
means but what it does mean is that you
control technology instead of it
controlling you because one of the items
it's exactly right and you be
intentional as weird as it is and as
hard as it is you be intentional about
having friends and making Making
Connections you be intentional about
taking care of your one precious body
the only thing you got most of us treat
our cars better than we treat our bodies
so there's several things we can do on a
regular basis that over time
man puts the fires out in our living
room and then the smoke detector doesn't
have to keep ringing off the wall yeah
when those brake pads wear out they tear
up the rotor yeah they do because they
did the metal on metal yeah I did that
I've done that a lot because I was too
broke to replace the brake pads so then
you get to spend eight times more
replacing the road or two yeah oh my god
oh yeah I do remember those days so
building a non-anxious life if you
pre-order today you'll get 75 dollars in
free bonus items including instant
access to the e-book the uh newest talk
smoke fire and freedom we'll ship you
the audiobook and the book two weeks
from today tomorrow on October the 3rd
and we want you to have this book and we
want you to be able to spread it around
it is an incredible incredible work just
go to ramseysolutions.com again if
you're listening to this on the 18th
you're catching the of September you're
catching the last possible day to get
the ebook early uh we'll still give you
the ebook but you'll just get on the
third when everybody else gets their
stuff so that's okay but I will send it
to you today if you buy it right now
right now ramseysolutions.com it'll come
today this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Cami Is With Us in
Springfield Illinois hi Cami welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi hi what's up
oh nothing I am a recently divorced
um Mama too and I just feel like I'm
extremely defined financially and I just
was looking for tips and advice on how I
get out of my situation that I'm in
currently
um
what what is his income your ex-husbands
um he makes about 45 an hour but I do
not take anything from him what do you
make
um I currently make 18 an hour and I'm a
personal trainer but I am only training
for like
like six to eight hours a week I think
we found your problem yeah no I know
I've been applying to jobs
um left and right
um it's just I cannot seem to find one
right now yes I know my issue is I don't
have enough income
um that's something that I'm working on
but I didn't know I don't know I just
don't know what to do are you only
applying to be a personal trainer
no I'm applying
I'm applying all over the place it's
just
yeah why aren't you why aren't you
taking why isn't he paying child support
um I was the one that wanted the divorce
and I it doesn't matter state law says
he pays child support yeah I know I just
didn't want anything ahead of the rest
of my life and I figured that I could do
it on my own and I want to be able to do
it I know that it was probably on
looking at it now but I think that when
I am finally successful and I am out of
my position that I'm in currently when
was the divorce final
um July
how have you lived since July on eight
hours a week
um I take I take shifts at the
restaurant that I worked at
there but I'm not scheduled I just take
shifts as they come he works a long
hours and we split the kids 50 50.
um but unfortunately with his work
schedule I have been the one that has
had to take the kids on the nights that
he has to work late so me getting a
full-time job for the longest time was
out of the question because our
babysitter actually got shut down for a
little while
um because she wasn't properly licensed
and so yeah I have just been living on
tax return
um tips that I'm getting the problem is
the problem is is that these priorities
have gotten all backwards on you
okay
um all of these things you're throwing
at me are solved
when you tell them all to take a side
seat because you have to work
and you have money
and when you have money because you're
working now you find a different
babysitter and you're not dealing with
some jack leg who's not even licensed
and gets put on the street and shuts
your whole operation down oh and by the
way when he calls and says he has to
work you say well I'm sorry you have the
kids I'm working
yeah
I think that you don't revolve your life
around all of these other people you set
your life up and they revolve around you
okay that's what's the problem do you
feel guilty that you filed for divorce
here
um I don't feel guilty no but I just
feel like any time that the kids are not
going to be prepared to take care of by
him I just feel like since I was a
stay-at-home mom for so long that it's
mine you're not a stay-at-home mom
anymore you made a decision to be a
career person now that's right and yeah
what you're trying to do is to have it
all at the same time with no pain that's
what I mean yeah you filed for divorce
you left them for whatever reason you
left him
and you can't eat
and so you're gonna have to put your ego
aside and possibly go back and say hey I
need some child support so our babies
have groceries well I'm trying to find a
job that's ego talking right now
he does have to pay me um 600 or 500 a
month
because we're currently on
um I am getting State assistance through
um link and medical insurance that is
not a good long-term plan it's not a
plan no it is not no I do not know that
plan is you working 40 to 50 hours a
week making 25 or 30 an hour and you can
get back where you can eat but you have
defined good mom as being there for
everyone except making money and I'm
redefining good mom as one who goes and
makes some money to provide for her
family because she's now a single mom
redefine it
a good mom is one now that works 45 or
50 hours a week and everyone else sits
to the side while you do that they you
figure it out because you cannot be at
home with the children anymore
right you don't have that option I'm
sorry I wish you could but the decisions
have been made that is now done
and so they are the best way you can be
there for them is go make some money not
because money makes the world go around
but it does buy food lights and shoes
and you're struggling to do that right
now
right and you're scared
yeah no it's it's a little bit uh scary
but I no it's a long time for yeah I
lived on my own for a little bit while I
was working full-time before the daycare
got shut down and within my place was
infested with molds I had to move out
and I'm currently living with my parents
and I do sell beef I raise cattle on the
side so I am Cami yes you need a job
sorry you need a job I know quit
explaining to me all the reasons you
don't
and working around the unlicensed
daycare and working around the husband
who took ex-husband who still tells you
when to jump and you jump all of this is
a re are not good enough reasons you
have got to get back to full-time
employment for the good of your children
your sanity yeah yeah you don't have a
choice and once you decide that then the
mold and the unlicensed daycare all
these other things start to move away
when you add three thousand dollars a
month to this equation
it changes the equation because money
what it does is it gives you options
it gives you power
it's not the money itself that matters
and I'm not all about money the room's
all about money single mom called me is
all about money now I want her feeder
dad gum kids and get the stress off of
her because she's scared to death but
your your head's spinning and all you
can do is just go into this Kaleidoscope
of reasons and excuses rather than going
and doing it and you have got to go do
it girl and this is not the time Dave
it's not the season for follow your
dreams and I'm going to start the dream
job and I'll show them this is not that
time no no no no no anyone who will hire
you I got to get a job that I can make
the most money and be the most impactful
and by the way
often when families get divorced mom and
dad think the greatest thing they can do
for the kids is FaceTime let me tell you
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is a present stable non-anxious mom and
dad
and that means you got to be able to pay
your bills you gotta be able to eat if
you're worried about your kids eating
while you're sitting in the floor
playing with them they're going to feel
that tension and they're going to absorb
it they're going to make it their fault
yeah you can't do that to your kids
exactly and keep that to your kids yeah
we we can't you know the best thing you
can do for you and them is is go make a
little money right now you don't need to
go make 300 000 a year but you do need
to go make 50. right now right now and
there's people doing that and so
um and so hang on we're going to give
you a copy of Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose and his other book
The Proximity principle and as soon as
they hit your mailbox I want you to sit
down and read them and turn the stupid
television off
you don't need to have a TV on in your
house at all right now yeah turn it off
reading these two books and you need to
be working call local school there's
people are so desperate for teachers
right now you've been a teacher as a
trainer start thinking outside the box a
little bit but call local schools and
see if you can get in as a as a teacher
yeah anything I mean Target's hiring ups
that we're coming into Christmas every
retail out there is hiring at 25 an hour
right now they can't get people and so
you can get the hours and you can get
the dollars coming in and but some of
these people are just gonna have to line
up in your life and stand to the side
instead of you being the one that stands
to the side every time that was the
moral of the story we heard when you
called us Cami so we love you and we
want you to win kiddo and understand why
you're scared but the chaos leaves when
you rise up above it and start telling
everybody where to dance instead of
being the one told when to dance this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and
remember Halo is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Justin's in Houston Texas Justin welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hello Dave uh thank you for taking my
call sure
um I was wondering about
um taking a loan out for home repairs uh
for the end goal being to sell the home
and I I know that uh that is as bad but
uh the situation is that I have two
elderly relatives with uh
um a fixed income and uh the houses that
they have fortunately are completely
paid off the issue is that they they
have like a significant damages to the
foundation to evolve a lot of it uh
they're safe to live in but I was
thinking perhaps if there's some uh if
an equity loan could be taken out
against it in order to fix those
significant issues and then sell off
those houses so that they can eventually
live in like a smaller place like a
condominium or a townhouse where uh they
wouldn't be burdened by the property
taxes that these houses are in
um if that would be acceptable in your
opinion
I would not do that no
because that's always with a story with
debt your story only works if it works
but I've been there when it doesn't work
like when these people with hardly any
income have a home equity loan the house
won't sell and the interest rates go
through the roof did you notice interest
rates have been rising
and now they're sitting there trapped oh
now they get foreclosed on
that's the people I've met
the debt plan only works when it works
and it hardly ever works because life
ever hardly ever works exactly the way
you map it out in your head
so yeah if everything worked exactly
like you said would that work yeah it
would work but it doesn't it's not how
life works
the contractor screws them
doing the basement repairs now they've
got all the debt and the repairs still
aren't quite done so but they've
borrowed all they can borrow now they're
trapped with a partially completed
construction project oh and then the
interest rates go up and then one of
them Falls ill
yeah this is this is this is how real
life unfolds here
so why wouldn't you just sell the houses
out right right now as is as is and get
the cash
well uh my concern is that the damage
are such that uh that the amount that
the houses would sell for would be
significantly less than that they could
potentially get yeah well that's true
but they're not in the real estate
investment business they're in the broke
old people business
yes that's correct and and that was like
in my my ideal vision is that they could
get as much money for their houses to be
able to sustain uh their retirement
they're in their 80s do you have any
money
uh I I do but uh not much money do you
have
um I have around my wife and I have
around 90 uh 8K in our uh retirement
accounts
um and then
um yeah that's and we we have no debt
we've been very blessed you don't have
the money to give them for this do you
no sir okay
you are a kind person Justin trying to
do something good for your grandma
grandpa or your uncle or aunt or whoever
it is and um but you're getting ready to
create a bigger mess because you don't
see all the unintended things that could
come about here that actually likely are
more likely than the um scenario that
you've laid out in your head that's what
I'm trying to describe to you so yeah I
would get with uh go to Ramsay Solutions
and click on Ramsay trusted for real
estate and get an agent to come over
there and tell them hey help me with
this because I don't want these people
have to give these houses away but they
simply don't have the money to fix them
and how can we get an investor in here
to give top dollar as is as John was
suggesting because that's where this
needs to go man I mean my grandparents
did the exact thing we're talking about
here the neighborhood they they were in
in the same city there in Houston was
starting to be gentrified and
they had some major work that need to be
done on the foundations the majority
been on the driveway they just sold the
house the guy came up and wrote him a
check in the driveway hand him a check
for the I mean it was it was transaction
yeah and because that's not it's not as
much as if it had been fixed up that's
right that's what his point is about
that but we're not in the house flipping
business right that's right that wasn't
there that wasn't their game to play and
they may have had to go to a different
nursing home or whatever but they didn't
they I mean it's just not the business
we're in you know broke 70 year olds
don't do rehabs for flips
that's what it amounts to especially on
margin especially especially when you're
borrowing a home equity loan on a paid
for a house it's just
um and that's that's being cold but
really this is the the actual fact of
what we're facing now how do we deal how
do we walk through it yeah well
um uh so I don't want them to have to
sell their house so cheap that decision
was made years ago when they didn't
bother to keep the maintenance up
now we're just having to execute the
decision that's when they gave up that
Equity was when they didn't do the
maintenance years ago and they didn't
take care of their money so that they
could but they chose to buy the houses
which is very instead of fixing up the
one yeah exactly exactly so yeah get get
with a Ramsey uh trusted real estate
agent there there's a bunch of really
good ones in Houston somebody will help
you try to get this and try to help get
these folks out of this because bless
their hearts are they're in a mess of
their own making but they're in a mess
and we don't want to make the mess
bigger which is what debt does
so
yeah the um the you know I I actually I
thought 100 years ago it feels like now
I was in a a Bible study and from a
Christian or spiritual perspective or a
Biblical perspective when you this guy
was pointing out it's not words we use
anymore because it's so long ago but he
said when you borrow you are presuming
and there's all kinds of scriptures
against presuming presumption don't
presume you know that the Lord don't
presume upon something you can't control
as as like the future
you know because who the cred knows
you're going to have a faucy quarantine
I mean who the crud knows you know
apparently Fout she did but the rest of
us did right I mean it's just like wow
so this is hey I grew up in the house of
somebody who worked at Enron don't tell
me no my business is secure no my
company is doing great
um like it just it's life we wouldn't
have jobs if if life didn't turn that
way man yeah if it turned out the way
you thought it was going to turn out
every time no nobody would be calling
and if you if you want to count on one
thing over the next 24 months while we
uh go through the presidential cycle
again it's going to get chaotic out
there so I wouldn't borrow imagine Tammy
is in Austin Texas hey Tammy what's up
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
[Music]
situation age no and retirement no okay
I had all kinds of money and I refused
to Pace to out-of-state tuition because
there's absolutely no value add for it
if you go to Auburn University versus
going to the University of Tennessee you
know what the difference is in your
education none
and you pay five times more
you know what the difference is you go
to Alabama versus University of
Tennessee Alabama wins at football
that's it that's the only difference
they used to until lately but yeah you
know what I'm saying I mean it doesn't
matter it's nothing the number of people
that we didn't hire here because they
went to in-state versus out of state is
zero
and a thousand employees
all right that's a hard no yeah it's a
hard no it's no value for it why would
she do that
dream school all of this and I'm sitting
here like do I give this to her do I
make this happen like you know you feel
guilty like I don't feel guilty my kids
got you know my kids had like an extra
fifty thousand dollars in a mutual fund
that was in their name when they
graduated because I didn't allow them to
spend it on out of state tuition
that's what I would rather do is yeah no
it's my money so I did it I did what I
wanted to do you're the mama you get to
do what you do yeah yeah hey and by the
way the whole ecosystem here's how the
game works because I've been on the
inside
let's make this kid believe that this is
the one
they use the same language that the kids
are taught to find the one that one
person that Romeo and Juliet
um like there's one person cruising The
World God got me into the school yeah
hey we saw you 17 year old and we picked
you University to fill in the blank and
then they you leverage that to make you
feel bad about it Mom and Dad and then
you write these checks that you you know
why you're writing them this is stupid
yeah don't do it we have a a local
private school called Brentwood Academy
ba stands for before Auburn
because they all go across the line to
Auburn for no apparent reason that's
what we call it before Albert before
Auburn yeah so and after all right
because they all follow their friends
and their brothers and sisters
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
just to be clear
we are not against higher education
we're not even against Auburn
although we used him as an example there
picking on them but the uh we I'm I I
see absolutely no logical reason that
presents itself with a return on
investment for why you would pay twenty
five thousand dollars to go to basically
the same school that you could go to for
10.
and it makes no sense at all and I can
go a step further and say those schools
that are quote famous unquote
the supposedly afford you a quote better
education unquote several of the people
that graduated from there worked for me
and I went to the University of
Tennessee
so kind of mic drops on that
uh that's how it works so you know the
question is not because what you are
after here is not a degree from a fancy
fancy place that guarantees your success
what you're after is a degree that
indicates that you got knowledge
knowledge is the currency not the degree
knowledge is the door opener not the
degree knowledge causes you to win in
the marketplace not the degree and if
you get knowledge about something that
no one gives a crap about you become a
barista
so you get a degree in left-handed
puppetry then you are waiting tables
are some nuanced bull crap that somebody
talked you into that has nothing to do
with anything in the real world then
your knowledge base that you paid for it
has no market for it you need to get
knowledge that has a market probably one
of the best bangs for your buck if
you're so inclined I'm not because my
brain doesn't work this way but if I was
a bit more of a detailed person which
would be like any more possible in any
detail at all would be more than I am
but if I was a detailed person I would
go to code school for ten thousand
dollars and go make 250 000 coding
I mean I would become one of the top
program programmers in the world and go
make you know 250 300 000 bucks coding
and you can get that for 10 grand
in my case I probably would end up you
know getting a welding certificate from
the trade school because I like that
kind of stuff but uh and you can make a
hundred thousand dollars doing that so
we're not against higher education
we're against paying for stupid things
that have nothing to do with furthering
your life and that is the name of the
college that you went to and that is a a
degree that is useless yeah
um man there's so much to be said there
I
just ask yourself what you're looking to
do not
um
don't ask a 17 year old or 18 year old I
think a very unfair question which is
what is your passion
um or where are your friends going yeah
yeah what's right for you and your
family what's right for where you think
you're going to be in a couple of years
what are you interested in right now and
um
and if coding's not for you then you can
never go wrong learning how to write
real well because it helps you think are
you if you're really into math go get a
degree in Business there's just so many
opportunities that you can get abroad
base so you can walk in any industry and
be be of service to those folks add
knowledge add knowledge and keep adding
relationships keep reading a book read a
non-fiction book this year hello a bunch
a bunch of them don't I mean if you're
if your entire repertoire is Tiger King
you're screwed I mean you really should
learn something of value that you can
use in the marketplace and uh so that
that this is very important and I'll
tell you there's one thing worse than
your kid going to school where all their
friends are going
it's if they go where their boyfriend or
girlfriend is going
why is that well if you follow if the
reason I'm going to the school is my
boyfriend or girlfriend is going there
yeah if that's your reason for picking
that school about a hundred percent of
the time approaching 100 that's that
deal is not going to last so I may have
done that Dave you might and you might
have it might have worked for you we
broke up two days into school
I did that I met somebody over the
summer completely I threw away 100 full
ride scholarship to one college went to
another school
because she was the one in my 18 year
old mind and we lasted 48 hours
but I met my current wife so it worked
out wow and what you got for that
forgiven scholarship is one story to
tell in front of 25 million people I
don't tell that story very often I
wouldn't I wouldn't have admitted it
everything that one goes in the old back
pocket
that one goes in the background
scholarships I still take I had several
and I do oh my God I still ask my mom
like how did how did y'all let me in
there like I don't know man I couldn't
stop you it was there was no stopping
you I mean they stopped me doing other
stuff but I don't know man oh the Ramsey
Show question of the day sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
most home American homes have dozens of
appliances chances are at any given time
something wrong with at least one of
them Mr Appliance a neighborly brand
offers expert appliance service to your
schedule visit neighborly.com today and
find Home Service Experts including Mr
Appliance in your area today's question
comes from Andrew in Nevada hey guys I
love listening to your show and it's
helped me give me a lot of comfort in my
life I've heard Dave says he gives a 10
tithe and I do as well and believe the
same my question is will there ever be a
time when you wouldn't tithe in order to
get yourself out of a bad financial
situation I was in a situation where it
was hard to tithe and I'm just cure
serious as to what thoughts you guys
have I realize this is probably more of
a spiritual question than a money
question
um what do you think
I'm 100 sure that your tithe has nothing
to do with your salvation
I'm 100 sure from scripture that God
loves you if you tithe or if you don't
tithe exactly the same he's wildly crazy
about you the purpose of the tithe is
not to get a Boy Scout badge in heaven
that's not the purpose of the tithe
your father who's crazy about you says
hon the best way to live your life is
give a tenth of your income off the top
before you do anything
and I'll love you anyway whether you do
that or not but your father says stay
out of debt because the borrower's slave
to the lender your father says don't
build a tower without first cutting the
calls unless you get halfway up and
you're unable to finish and all who see
you begin to mock you and
this man began to build and was unable
to finish that's Jesus's words sing to a
budget
don't bill without a plan
don't build without a plan that's just
your father none of these things affect
his love for you or your salvation
so Tyler don't tithe God still loves you
now if my dad who's crazy about me and
knows more than me says tithe I tithe
but it has nothing to do with earning
anything the my grace is taken care of
it's substantial
it's substantial it's taken care of so
you know it's way more crazy to answer
your question I tithe all the way into
bankruptcy court and all the way out but
it had nothing to do with I was scared
of God it had nothing to do with I was
trying to earn his favor it had to do
with apparently
you can live on ninety percent of
whatever if you're not making much and
you're having a hard time it's not it's
ten percent of not much
and so I did I tied all the way in all
the way out and it wasn't because I'm a
legalist and it wasn't because of that
it was because I I think it's the best
way to live just like I think staying
out of debts the best way to live yeah I
I like to look at some of these
um quote unquote rules these scriptural
rules as
they're not this is the best way to live
your life they're not rude it's a gift
it's the best exactly so
um there's something about giving
there's something about a spirit of
gratitude that keeps your head your eyes
out of your navel and helps you look up
and see your neighbor it just changes
the way you you work your way through
life and there's something about meeting
people eye to eye hand to hand that
changes the way you your heart beats and
so I think this is much less a it is a
spiritual question more than a money
question but it's actually a
physiological question it's a
relationship question it's a way to do
life it's a way to do life and and your
father who
it is The Great I Am who's standing
there five years from now knows where
you're going to be and they've stand
there five years ago and knows where you
came from at the same time not bound by
time is is saying son best way to live
and so I'm it's for me it's just like
it's a it's an Act of Faith at that
point faith in in that but it's not but
if someone says uh you can't you can't
be blessed because God because you're
not tithing not true yeah not true at
all not true can't find it in scripture
oh you can find scripture taken out of
context to point to that but um God is
not God does not need your money he's
God if he wanted your money he'd take it
and there'll be a greasy spot where
you're sitting he's God he doesn't need
your money
but he wants you to win he wants you to
have an abundant life this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and author of the brand new book
coming out in two weeks building a
non-anxious life is my co-host today
thanks for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Peter is with us in Miami Florida
hi Peter welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you thank you how can we
help
so I I I'm wondering what role you think
I should play in helping my financially
irresponsible mother
um
you know one of the things that it's
weird about that question uh for a lot
of us is when we face that is it seems
like money is in a different category
than other misbehavior
if you changed out her misbehavior for
something else
a different kind of misbehavior or
irresponsibility
um what would the how would the answer
change it shouldn't really should it it
ought to be the same answer so in other
words if we wanted to go extreme and say
how do I help my mom who's addicted to
cocaine right well it wouldn't be give
her more
right it would be help her break the
habit and transform her life that's help
is not doing more of the bad thing
help is correcting the behaviors so and
of course the person that involves the
person on the other end wanting the help
yeah that's I usually run into parents
don't want your help they want your
solution right
yeah I was she she just has no issues uh
you know coming to me again and again
and again and again and a nibble here
and a bite here and you know I I know
that the big bite is coming but hold on
hold on why wouldn't she come to you
because you give it to you every time
right I know and so at this point I
don't even believe it you're a
Dependable enabler yeah I don't blame
her anymore
I am I am and you know it's it's the the
nibbles I don't mind and I know that
this is not the bad thing to say but
that's what got her to the bite
and you know next thing I know she's
telling me that she rents she rents her
house because she's been bankrupt Etc so
she can't get a mortgage and she can't
frankly afford a mortgage down here
anymore
um so she came to me because she needed
money for movers she needed money for
her security deposit her first month
last month which I did all of that
uh and then I sort of dug into a
finances and realized that you can't
even afford this rent
so I tried to get ahead of that and
fortunately I'm doing very well for
myself and my family but I'm doing well
for myself and my family and I've got
two young children and a wife and a
mortgage and a business to run
um so I I just so um how long has this
been going on
oh I mean her financially no you giving
her money you giving her money how long
has she been going on uh probably five
six seven years how old is she
about 73. oh
and she's Stone broke
yeah and recently widowed which only you
know made me softer by my stepfather
passed two years ago three years ago so
obviously that I was trying to help and
what do you make
uh
uh Family household income is probably
three quarters of a million okay and
um so it's not a matter of you can't or
can you can mathematically yeah it's a
matter of what's good for her she's 73
she's probably not very employable
um I guess she has social security job
I'm sorry she does have a full-time job
she does have a full-time job okay
I retract that statement what does she
do
uh she's a uh customer service and she
has been for about 20 years the same job
but you know
she's one fall away from yeah not being
able to work anymore yeah okay so
I'll tell you the financial answer and
I'll let John tell you the psychological
answer okay uh the financial answer if
I'm in your shoes is I'm going to sit
down with her and say mom you have this
coming in
from your Social Security you have this
coming in from your job
and these are your bills let's do out
let's do a budget together
and um you can make your bills
or you're within 400 of making your
bills or whatever it is okay and uh so I
am not going to write checks
just from today on without us having a
sense of control over what's going on
here so I'll help you and Coach you with
your money but um it looks to me like
you have enough to live on
and I'll help you and Coach you live on
that or if you don't have enough to live
on I'm gonna give you two thousand
dollars a month so that you have enough
to live on this 24 000 out of 750 000
you can afford it but you say this is
what we're doing but then the she needs
to
um
just it it's you're becoming bitter and
I would too yes because you feel like an
ATM machine
exactly and then there's an entitlement
that goes with this on her end and so I
would shut all of that down and just say
okay this is a system and we're going to
live by this system and uh draw some
boundaries and Mom if you don't want to
do that what I'm if you don't want to
live on the budget that you and I put
together and that I check on you to make
sure you're living on that budget then
um then I'm not going to help you
anymore
and you're gonna have to just figure it
out because it's not good for you what
I've been doing and I'm sorry I've let
you down
John what would you do yeah I
I wonder if you're more frustrated with
yourself than with her right now oh yeah
yeah I I it's just every time I try to
get ahead of it you know for example
when she was looking at this rent
um I said you know what I'm just gonna
buy her an apartment and then she can
just pay me you know what she can afford
I I was going to buy her an apartment
outright and I was scrambling because
she was looking for a rental and she
couldn't afford none of these places
could she afford because we kind of not
a deep dive but we looked at our
finances and then I realized okay it's
this is just easier for me to buy an
apartment at least then I can consider
it a quote-unquote investment of some
sort
um and I presented her with it and she
said no I don't want to live there I'm
just going to rent this other place and
hold on and that's where you who are
clearly
a special businessman to be able to make
the money you make
you're clearly very smart and I would be
willing to bet nobody in your in your
sphere
blows past you like that but she does
right and I don't want you to consider
um sitting down at the table and saying
I'm looking that you at the fact that
you may be around until you're 93 20
more years
we have to put some things in concrete
right now
I want you to tattoo this phrase on the
middle of your forehead choose guilt
over resentment every time
because right now you're backing
yourself into a corner because you won't
set boundaries and you're beginning
every time your mom calls you get angry
yes and your mom quite frankly deserves
better than that and that means you have
to set the boundaries up and then she is
a 73 year old adult can say I hate you
you don't even love me and you walk away
she's a grown-up and she gets to do that
I would hate that but she gets to do
that your job is to create boundaries
that are sustainable for 20 years from
this point forward and by the way sit
with your wife and you all decide what
y'all are going to do to help her
um before you sit down with your with
your mom yeah how much you're willing to
do but the unlimited
thread being pulled on the sweater is
killing both of you yeah you got to cut
it this
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
guarantee and
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
visit blinds.com to get up to 45 off
that blinds.com rules and restrictions
May apply
[Music]
open phones this hour at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Dr Chon the
um
I I don't really have a good exact
checklist or anything but just general
observation over 30 years of doing this
on the air and working with people
um one of the
I'll just make it up top five pain
points
that people have with money
is
um
how to properly
be compassionate kind loving
to extended family grown children
that have problems how do we you know
children that are out of the house or
that should be out of the house uh
parents brother sister
uh extended family
uh that that we see that they have a
need or they bring us a need either one
and then how to appropriately deal with
that the whole issue of boundaries Dr
Henry Cloud sold 10 million boundaries
books off of that concept
but the whole our Buddy Henry but the uh
uh that whole issue is
you know mathematically it probably
causes almost as much disruption in
someone's wealth building Journey as
anything else
keeps you from becoming wealthy
and is it the lack of when I don't fully
unders understand what my values are on
money when I fully don't understand my
own footing
is that where is that where the
challenges come from I don't want family
members in my mind it's reduced simply
to we don't know how to establish proper
boundaries and a boundary can be that I
agree to help somebody a boundary can be
I agree to say I decided I'm going to
say no but we don't have that cut that
part of our compass
is as it's as toxic as some families are
but it's like that last caller gets mad
that somebody keeps coming into space
but he's never done the work to Define
his space exactly and so you have to do
the hard work and say this is for me and
my house this is what we make that's
what we have is what we can do and then
ask would we do that and why and those
are questions that people don't like to
ask well but I mean when you're uh
there's a book called Glass Castle uh
that is a a lady that was a MSNBC
reporter
um very well known and she was raised in
an extremely weird toxic dysfunctional
family both of her parents as she's an
adult were living on the street in New
York while she's working at MSNBC wow
they were homeless wow they chose but
they were kooky but um I mean it's a
great read just because it's like oh
just in case you thought your family was
crazy you know what I think but the uh
uh but yeah but the uh
you know she felt helpless to fix them
but they chose homelessness in that case
you can't make these adults behave the
only thing you can control is your space
and that's so hard for people it's so
hard it's so hard but like that last
caller there has there I guess let's say
this way there will be a confrontation
yep that will happen and the earlier you
can have it the the lower it tends to be
and so in that last situation where he's
thinking I'm just going to buy her an
apartment I found one that I can afford
I'll write a check for it and call it
good and she said I'm not living there
that's when the conversation happens
then I'm not putting a penny towards the
choices you're choosing to make yeah you
can you can figure it out I'm not doing
that this is open invitation for you
right here and that's a hard
conversation but she has no motivation
to even not live where she wants to
because she knows he's gonna give me the
money yeah and it's the same way with
kids the same way with neighbors the
same way with family members but there's
a
and Cloud talks about and I guess
there's the first chapter maybe even in
that book
um that when you
set a boundary with someone who doesn't
respect boundaries
100 of the time you can expect a
negative reaction always pouting
guilt-tripping anger
none of them go oh well I never thought
of it that way I'm so sorry and think of
it like you built a fence and your
neighbor's thrown rocks at it hitting it
with sticks everyone's going to use the
tools that they have to try to get you
to open the gate up and
don't yeah and that's hard that's just a
boundary but man it is really it's hard
it causes more heartache
uh and literally then does end up
driving a wedge between a husband and
wife because one of them's helping the
other ones I'm I'm choosing my uh my
crazy brother who won't get a job over
my wife's wishes you know and that
drives a wedge in their marriage and it
just it slows down wealth building and
it's not to say you can't help extended
family or you shouldn't help but this
idea that we're morally obligated to
meet their every wish
just because they hit the DNA Lottery
and happen to be kin to us I think it's
the I think it's something else okay I
actually think
um if you if you flip this conversation
on its head we use our family members
to help us feel better about ourselves I
don't want to be uncomfortable that my
mom is in position X or Y so I'm just
gonna do whatever and when you do that
you're actually consuming her you're
using her
to make you feel better
and I'm not going to do that I'm going
to sit in the discomfort so that we're
all better 5 10 15 20 years from now
um it's like going to the gym and taking
all the weights off the bar that that
sure makes the workout easier but ain't
nobody get any stronger and so I'm not
going to use my 14 year old and her
approval
to make me feel better about myself I'm
going to have the hard conversation so
you can't talk like that in this home
and it's really when you say choose
guilt over resentment it's also you
could be choosing their anger
over resentment yeah of course you could
be choosing their disapproval over
resentment
whatever whatever way they choose to hit
back when you draw a boundary over
resentment right because you're going to
be resentful if you remain in the
enabler seat right and your spouse is
going to be 10x as resentful as you are
if you remain in the enabler seat and in
a less caustic situation let's say my
mom calls and says or sends an email and
says we want you all to come to
Christmas the whole family's coming
we're really expecting you all to be
there
and we can't travel this year or our
family's exhausted we don't have the
money whatever
I can say yes and the whole time I'm
driving there I'm gonna be mad at her
the whole time I'm sitting at the meal
I'm gonna be mad that's not fair to her
it's fair to her to say we're not coming
we're unable to make that trip this year
we're not gonna be able to do it and
then she gets to be an adult and do
whatever reactions on the back end of
that she wants to do but the fair thing
is I'm not going to spend a weekend not
liking my mom I'd rather feel guilt I'd
rather listen to her responses than to
sit there and smolder the whole weekend
and by the way your kids learn how to
treat in-laws when you do that or your
mother when you do that you're modeling
to everybody how to live I'm just not
going to do that anymore I'm gonna set
the boundaries and they're going to be
hard and I have to be in a position to
let other adults walk away if they don't
approve or like my boundaries on
something
you know I think Sharon and I went to
the extreme other end on that we may
have messed up the other way what's that
um
we don't put any expectations
for the holidays and uh and we have
fallen in love with our in-laws so
Winston's mom and dad I mean Winston's
going on Dad's going on a hunting trip
with me in two weeks yeah you know
without Winston yeah and without my son
you know and because buddy and I like
each other you know and so buddy and
Helen and Dave and Sharon do stuff the
same same with uh Bill's parents same
with Allison's parents so the in-laws
were actually friends with them and we
made that an intentional act that's cool
but they're also cool people that's cool
and uh you know we'll travel together I
mean Buddy's gone you know we've gone to
Mexico together done other stuff and so
that's cool that we gone on golfing
trips with all of us all the guys all
three all three grandpas that's pretty
cool that's fun so um you know we'll do
that kind of stuff but we intend it and
then when Thanksgiving comes up and the
kids go ah we're going to Kansas City to
Allison's parents good yeah you should
knock it out should and um then we'll
just figure it out we see you all the
time by the way they're all they're here
they're all here in Nashville so yeah so
we got it made in that regard but it
doesn't it's not like we're perfect or
something but we just went to the
extreme of full release yeah and and the
happiness the secret to happiness is low
expectations hello but there's a strange
phenomenon Dave that when you fully
release it it tends to come back it
tends to come back but it works out it
does it works out because again it's
just if you don't have these
expectations you don't stay screwed up
and torqued out all the time that's
right and that's the same true of
somebody else's money and the people
want to be around you and you're not
talked out all the time it just tends to
work that way yeah and again that's a
type of boundary situation so this is
very interesting discussion it's
something I've observed here for 30
years so setting boundaries with the
extended family on money
all right
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Rick is
in Boston hi Rick welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
65 years old
and wondering if I'll be able to retire
at 72 and be okay with my current
situation
yeah okay what's your current situation
okay well
um I'm very healthy and very well in
shape I have a great job I plan on
continuing to work
um I still owe 136 000 on my home I
would like to have that paid off by the
time I do my retirement at 72.
um I have a truck
um 30 000 on the truck
and
um in March of this year I installed
solar on my my roof
um I'm not sorry I did that uh that was
a twenty two thousand dollar I bought it
out right twenty two thousand dollar
loan
um is it a loan or did you buy it
uh well it's it's through a uh um I took
out a solar loan okay 22 000 in debt on
solar what else correct uh 18 left on
that by the way
um trying to pay trying to pay that off
I have not yet received my federal uh
percentage my Temperance taxes next year
but that's going on there so that'll be
down to like nine grand probably in
March of next year
um I have 110 401k
I have 5 000 emergency
and I have zero credit card debt
I do what do you mean
uh 100 Grand a year
okay
I pay alimony approximately
um just about 10 000 a year I have until
November of 24. okay what I would do if
I were in your shoes is I would get
these two debts paid off immediately
stop adding to your 401k temporarily and
I want you I want the truck and the
solar paid off inside of 12 months
really beans and rice rice and beans you
have no life until you get that done
that is that is job one it's an
emergency or sell the stupid truck one
of the two
well I can't that's you know my only
vehicle well you could get another
vehicle you're in your thirty thousand
dollar one but uh yes you can so that
actually it's it's a sixty thousand
dollar truck I only owe 30 grand on it I
have good then you can sell it and get a
thirty thousand dollar car okay yeah I
sell it right now buy ten thousand
dollar car and pay that other debt off
too yeah yeah yeah yeah because you
don't have any money yeah well you're 65
years old and you're broke
yeah
um so here's here's I had a plan let me
let me tell you what my plan was you
tell me if you think this would work if
this is good or not and I've totally
listened to you guys
um in in 14 in 14 months
um my alimony payments stopped so that's
another 10 grand that I have that I was
thinking about
um putting back into my 401k and trying
to catch up
um I'm also going to be hit my full
retirement age so I can start taking my
Social Security which is about 3 200 a
month and I was going to try and pay off
the loans with that the house and the
truck well the solar by that but the
solar I'm not really worried about
because I've been making a lot of
payments on that and that'll be just
about gone
um but between the house and the truck I
with my you know and continue to work
um I thought maybe because you know what
do you figure 30 3 200 a month in um
Social Security yeah you're about 500 or
600 000 behind
yeah I know yeah and so um no I think
your plan's too slow I would get more
radical if I was in your shoes I would
get a 30 000 truck I would sell this one
or ten thousand dollar truck and I pay
off the stuff by Christmas I'd be debt
free other than the house uh and every
dollar I can squeeze out I'm then going
to start putting 15 of my income into
retirement and everything else towards
this house and I want the house paid off
in like three years
not in seven years and then I want you
just loading up 401ks and Roth IRAs and
anything else you can load up in good
mutual funds then you will end up with
about four or five hundred thousand
dollars in a paid for house at 72. the
track you're on right now you're going
to end up with about 250 000 in a paid
for house at 72.
and that that there's about a 250 000
swing in what you're planning to do and
what I'm teaching you
but I'm teaching you some sacrifice you
don't really want to do
and you got to quit saying crap like the
cellular was a good idea it wasn't a
good idea broke people don't spend 22
000 on cellular solar solar whatever it
is yeah don't buy cellular either you
gotta quit buying money and borrowed
money
you don't have any you don't have any
money that's my point you got to stop
this you can't you can't talk about this
is this is okay this is okay this look
it's not okay it's killed you man I mean
you make good money and you got
virtually no money
so um
I mean I'm not saying you're horrible
but you're a c minus student at this
this is not an A plus you're not you
didn't flunk you're not you're not
retiring it with Social Security only
that's flunking right but uh but you
know you you got to lean into this and
yeah I'm with John if I woke up in your
shoes what would I do I'm about your age
I mean I'm 63. so if I woke up in your
shoes I'd be driving a ten thousand
dollar truck I'd be debt free and I'd
have a game plan knock that 136 out so
fast it's unbelievable meanwhile dumping
everything else I can find into my 401k
getting a you know Roth IRAs and load
those puppies up because here's the
thing
Seven Years it'll double
whatever you're doing whatever you got
in your lump sum today it'll double
if it's in good mutual funds so that 110
that's there will be two will be 220.
and your house will be paid for that's
your 250 000 I'm talking about that's
what you'll have uh you might have a
little bit more than that if you if you
get aggressive on putting some in you
might have 300 but you could you could
have 600. and we thought and then you
can buy a truck we talked about this
earlier the confrontation will come and
this conversation is going to be between
you and math it's coming you can you can
manage it on your terms right now and
make some sacrifices some pretty hard
sacrifices or you can just wait and it
will hit you at 88 in your ward of the
state yep
Ellen's with us in Atlanta hi Ellen
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you hey Dave hey John really
appreciate your show sure
um
16 goal and I am trying to decide
whether to
take out a loan on a house or a
townhouse or to buy my net worth is
about 4 million why would you borrow
money
advised me to do that I would get a new
Financial advice yeah they're fired
oh bye Felicia you you have more money
than he does
and how did you get there how did you
get there not by his advice you got
there by using your common sense
yeah well and your common sense is
telling you to pay cash for this
yeah it is and your financial advisor is
confusing you
yes I'm very confused pay cash
um okay I'm interested even how did he
come to this oh he wants her to invest
the money with him yeah he wants to hold
on to your money because if you buy a
house with cash he loses that investment
money right so he has a financial
interest in you not doing what's best
for you but I'm interested in his
argument it's she can make more on the
investment he
um that mortgage mortgage rates are
going to go down and they'll be more I
guess more inventory on the housing
market so maybe prices will go down
within the year
um yeah you really you really need a new
guy on
okay okay because there's a there's a
housing shortage we've got the lowest
inventory in 15 years on the market
right now there's only a million
properties on the market right now
there's usually three million on the
market so when you have that kind of a
shortage prices don't go down they go up
anytime there's a shortage like that so
we're not going to see house prices go
down not substantially they're probably
going to go up about seven percent in 23
that's what all the projections are this
guy is playing games with his math
um that's dangerous and you need to
trust you you are wiser than he is trust
your instincts I would pay cash for it
if I were in your shoes and of course
you called Dave Ramsey you knew he was
going to say that so this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today and is with us in San
Diego hi and welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
sure I love all your answers today
especially the one about tithing oh
thank you how can we help so yes okay so
I
000 in mutual funds
um which generates a monthly income for
me of about two thousand dollars and
that two thousand dollars is about a
third of my total income for the month
um my question to you is I've got a car
loan out for it's twenty thousand
dollars total and I just was informed
that we have to pay back our student
loans which will be about
twenty five thousand dollars
how old are you the question is
I'm
67. okay all right so you're retired and
this is your next day yes
and what is it invested in
mutual funds
okay so they're making more than
twenty four hundred dollars a month or
two thousand dollars a month was it
but you're just not taking all of it out
right exactly okay good good
okay so would I rather have
three hundred thousand and no doubt or
350 000 with debt
um
now the question is should I pay off the
student loan and the car loan with my
mutual funds yes
is that your only is that your only
money is that three hundred and fifty
thousand
oh no no no oh
how much money elsewise do you have
elsewise I have a retirement I have a
pension and social security okay the
retirement is a nest egg or what
uh it's it's a monthly income okay so
you have a bunch of monthly income but
in terms of money that you have
in actual Savings of any kind retirement
or otherwise this 350 is it
exactly yes gotcha your home is paid for
it is good for you so you don't even
need the income off of this you could
live off of the other streams of income
couldn't you
I could but not as comfortably oh yeah
yeah sure okay right all right so I
suspect that your decrease in what you
would draw if you were drawing on 300
rather than on 350. would be less than
the payments that you're going to pay
off so I would imagine you have a net
gain
right so I'd pay it off today
with the mutual funds yes
that's going to reduce your income it's
going to reduce your income from the
mutual fund but it's also going to
reduce your outgo for these two payments
exactly and of course your financial
advisor said don't do this
yeah he like shook his head of course he
did you know the he said like the market
is like really volatile right now to me
yeah it's like way up
yes and listen when it's way down he's
going to say it's really volatile just
leave it to me I'll take care of you
yeah exactly so if you pull this money
out and pay your debt off he's going to
make less money let me tell you
something else that's gonna happen man
that's really hard to believe
okay you're gonna feel
physically different
when you don't have any debt at all it's
so weird yeah
I it's hard to describe to people some
people it's more dramatic than others it
just depends on how much of a warrior
you are the more of a warrior you are
the more you'll feel it
because you know
John always says your body keeps the
score it's it's you're you physically
register the fact that you owe money and
for the last three years even though you
could pay it off tomorrow you've been
playing ping pong with the government on
who's paying your loans back you them
them you you them how do you have a
student loan at 67. what could you do
yeah what did you do did you go back to
school like at 62
oh well it's my daughter's oh it's a
parent plus
yes oh okay okay all right well that
makes more sense uh sort of but yeah
yeah definitely yeah if I if I woke up
in your shoes is the way I answer
questions here
knowing what I know and my net worth is
greater than that of your financial
advisor
um and so you know there's a lot of ways
we can measure expertise in this area if
you want but that's one of them
um I would pay I would pay to uh I mean
I'd pay that loans off today
and take a little bit smaller draw but
you would have a smaller out go and
you'll still have approximately the same
net cash flow in your budget maybe a
little bit better net cash flow in your
budget from doing this so it won't
affect your life except that you're not
gonna owe anybody
and you're done
and very few people become wealthy using
borrowed money to do it
most people become wealthy using cash
flow and so you're not you're not adding
to your wealth by holding these debts
Dave I must start getting all worked up
that's the second caller today that is
called in the shower in this hour that
has a financial advisor
doing something against their best
interest to their client
yeah it there's two types of people
though there honestly like there isn't a
lot of things number one there's
financial advisors that um are straight
up just doing it because they make more
money you know just a straight up ethics
issue as far as you and I are concerned
against their best interests the second
thing is is they just honestly disagree
they would go borrow on a car to put
money in mutual funds
they really believe that or they would
go borrow on your house to put money in
mutual funds they really believe that
they're wrong but they really believe it
and so my contention is you actually get
screwed More Often by enthusiastic
ignoramuses
absolutely yeah there's more
enthusiastic agreements out there I did
one for a long time yeah I've been one
yeah I've never been a con artist right
I've never purposefully with evil and
benevolence just taken uh you know the
idea I'm a steal from somebody or I'm
gonna hurt somebody so that I get gained
I have never done that in my life ever I
don't not a single time but I have
enthusiastically endorsed some
absolutely ridiculous things me too yeah
not for the last 30 years but uh but
prior to that man I got a PhD in stupid
yeah I I can tell you story after Story
of stupid butt stuff I've told people to
do help them do it encourage them to do
it forcefully and passionately argued
stupidity I have done that oh my god
I've done that when I or a younger man's
clothes but yeah I know it sounds a lot
like when you convince me to jump out of
an airplane with you too
you lived and you got a great story no
whining great story no whining pretty
awesome yeah pretty awesome and it was
um it was fun it was a lot of fun we
need to do it again it's about time but
um I think
um hey I would do that tomorrow uh you
got me hooked but I do think it's
important for people to remember if
you've amassed wealth and you've done
well for yourself and you've got
somebody saying hey this is the right
way it reminds me of there's there's a
great documentary out where there's a
bunch of grandmothers and they're
sitting there talking about margarine
and they said everyone told us that
margarine was better for us than just
pure butter
and they started trying to get this
margarine out of the tubs with like a
spatula and they to a person said we
knew it in our bones this wasn't right
but they told us and so we just went
with it and it wasn't good and so it's
very similar if your guts tell you this
is wrong let's do something else which
by the way margarine is colored lard ugh
just in case you're wondering
with a side of chemicals yeah this is
why when you get real butter at a
gourmet restaurant your brain freaks out
it lights up like Christmas because
you've been eating colored lard yeah oh
my gosh you know that that's the truth
we did we grew up on that stuff yeah
yeah and you know the things we were
told these preservatives keep the food
from going but they're so good for you
but they destroy your body you grew up
in the uh in the Menthol tab margarine
era the golden era of American nutrition
I grew up where every adult in my life
could cuss the highway patrolman with a
cigarette hanging out of their mouth and
never leave their mouth that's where I
grew up that you know there's so much
nicotine in the house it was running
down the walls and smoking sections in
on the plane are my favorite memory
exactly yeah as if it wouldn't run its
way down this hollow aluminum tube and
the whole place filled up with smoke as
if the smoke would obey the little sign
that said smoking section
they had them in restaurants too if only
they'd had someone tell them to wear
masks they would have been much safer
you know who who would think of that I
don't know fouchy oh who knew before
that was before America got fouchied
yeah this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America I'm Dave Ramsey George Campbell
Ramsay personality co-host of the smart
money happy hour and uh recently back
from Chicago with all of us we just
finished up doing a smart conference
there a lot of fun and we appreciate you
guys hanging out with us up there we'll
be letting you know when other things
are happening around here that you can
join into meantime the phone number here
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Kyle is in Boise Idaho hi Kyle
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey George thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so uh I've been a fan of the show for
about two months my wife got me hooked
on the show I've been listening ever
since thank you I just correct you just
graduated from a graduate school
um got my degree in the nurse anesthesia
so I'm a certified registered Nursing
messages yeah wonderful field so you got
the new job yet
I just got a new job still waiting what
are you making 300.
I'm starting at 2 20. yeah very good
good for you awesome proud of you
so my my uh my debts you know all I have
as far as debt is my student loans which
is actually 220 000. wow which was what
it was to go through graduate school to
do anesthesia so my question is I just
you know I'm not I haven't been good at
managing money
you know fortunately I'll have his
student loans but I'm like what do I do
like what's my next step in life do I
you know do I get into a house you know
I you know throw everything in my debt
to get out of debt yeah what do I do
from here
you're gonna keep living how you've been
living what's the most you were making
past few years
um so again how much am I making how
much did you make before this
started the anesthesia school I was
working as a nurse
and I was thinking about 22 bucks an
hour yeah so can you keep living as if
you're making 22 bucks an hour and throw
the rest of it at your debt
probably not probably that's the hardest
part because right now you graduated you
get the big boy job everyone's going
dude you're making the big bucks how are
you still driving that beater car yeah
it's not okay it wasn't enough can you
it's a question of will you
yeah see that's where my son married I
was GM children yeah and everyone's like
oh you got all this money my
mother-in-law's like you should you can
afford that form there's a lot of broke
people now speaking in now that you hit
the lottery
you know I spoke to a financial advisor
briefly and she's like
oh no you know start saving for
retirement and put money here put money
here I'm like I got you know I've almost
got a quarter of a million dollars in
the student loans yeah what does your
wife mean
so she's uh by you know she went to
school for the interior design she's
staying home now with the kids
but we just have the one income okay all
right so you make 220 000 a year and if
you were to live on
sixty thousand you would be debt free in
18 months
and you have the rest of your life to
make a quarter of a million to three
hundred thousand dollars a year with no
payments in the world and you will
become very wealthy and you have a
different financial advisor and then
your relatives will be asking you what
to do instead of telling you what to do
with money because you will not be a
broke a version of them
okay the other the other aspect too is
you know I'm a 1099 contractor with the
hospital
and that you know has thrown me off too
I'm like well now I gotta you know I
gotta pay on my own taxes and buy health
insurance and we'll do all this other
stuff that's
Whoopi you make 220 000 a year just set
your taxes aside
go buy some health insurance
and oh by the way you can actually pick
up overtime too
yeah okay you can work on the weekends
in ER can't you
um I I can't actually but I got you know
part of my contract gives me 10 weeks of
vacation a year which I could
maybe use you know to find employment on
those weeks off not maybe your 220 000
in debt absolutely
so if you're in my position throw
everything at that then
so
yeah that's what I've been saying for
the last five minutes the um the uh uh
the way I'm answering this is if I were
in your shoes here's what I would be
thinking okay
as far as I'm concerned here's what I
think you did maybe you didn't but I
think you said I'm a nurse
if I was in anesthesiology as a nurse I
could make three times more than I make
now or four times more than I make now
or even five times more than I make now
I'm going to go get this degree so that
I can make a lot more money so that I
can have a lot more money at the end of
the story and have my a better life for
my family during the story is that what
you were thinking
yeah then for God's sakes go get rid of
the debt so you can have a lot more
money
make sense okay yeah and get a different
financial advisor this one's a goob
and talk to when you're ready right now
you don't need one you just need Dave
telling you you don't need to talk to
them that one's not got us you know stay
in 220 000 worth if you have a financial
advisor this is stay in 220 000 worth of
student loan debt run out of their
office like your hair is on fire
my God
that's just dumb but what do you what do
you think they're gonna say they want
you to invest with them so they can put
food on the table they're not going to
be helping you getting out of debt
that's what you call this show for yeah
let's just um do a little sidebar here
for a second
your financial advisor's job is not to
tell you what to do
if they think it is get you a different
one
85 percent of the people in the
financial World whether they're
insurance or mortgage or
uh Brokers or planners or whatever are
sales people 15 of them are teachers
I made that number up but it's pretty
close
you want one that has the heart of a
teacher not the heart of a Salesman
you've got one Kyle that has the heart
of a Salesman
do what I do because I have three
letters after my name let me tell you I
got a whole bunch of freaking letters
after my name and one of them is a PhD
in dumb
so which qualifies me infinitely more
than them plus I have all the degrees
that they've got most of them anyway
I don't have my cfp my Certified
Financial Pharisee
um I don't have that one but yeah but
anyway yeah it's not all of them are
Pharisees some of them are really good
folks but anyway you want a financial
person whoever it is in any category to
have the heart of a teacher their job is
not to tell you what to do
their job is to teach you and then you
can decide what to do and this stuff is
not that complicated you can do it well
people call the show and they say oh
Dave my financial advisor they made me
they didn't make you do anything
you chose and you didn't speak up and so
that's what we're wanting you to do here
is get yourself educated you make the
decisions
[Applause]
but Kyle excellent career choice
phenomenal
go make a big pile of money for you and
your family and the first order of
businesses get this mess cleaned up the
second order of businesses start to
build some wealth the third order of
businesses get your house paid off
this is what we want you to do for your
sake by the way we didn't charge
anything for this and we don't need
anything from you we just love you and
we want you to win this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Nick Murray published
this essay in a financial planning
uh periodical that I got a hold of this
week one of my buddies sent it to me in
the business it's very well done and
he's kind of he's kind of a snarky like
you George that's why I like him I like
just reading this article yeah the
persistent illusion of gold
this is good yeah for the second for the
record the subtitle of the Wall Street
Journal piece is swings in stocks and
bonds have boosted the metals popularity
with ordinary Investments the statistic
at the heart of the article is the
percentage of Americans who believe gold
is the best long-term investment jumped
to 26 percent this year from 15 in 2022
according to a Gallup report from May
wow in contrast those preferring stocks
dropped to 18 from 24 last year while
those favoring bonds climbed to seven
percent from four percent this happens
quite reliably every time there's a bear
Market in stocks ordinary investors are
always recalibrating their preferences
in the rear view mirror
my which is wrong my major purpose in
this little essay is to parse through
the pathology which persists in the
illusion not just that gold is an
efficient inflation hedge but that it
somehow preferable to holding a broadly
Diversified portfolio of high quality
Common Stocks like a mutual fund for the
long term first let's get our
terminology straight gold is not in any
accepted sense an investment at all that
is it does not produce anything it just
sits there goals sole Financial function
is as an inflation hedge the question
then becomes how's that working out in
August of 71 the price of gold was
arbitrarily fixed at thirty five
thousand dollars an ounce thirty five
dollars an ounce by January of 80 the
last time ordinary investors went
totally Gaga over it gold had reached
eight hundred dollars an ounce thus if
you bought an ounce of gold nearly 44
years ago at eight hundred dollars you
now own an ounce of gold that is at this
riding worth nineteen hundred and sixty
five dollars that's up about two and a
half times having produced in the
interim neither dividends nor interest
nor anything else
it now becomes my painful duty to
disclose to you that the Consumer Price
Index in January of 80 stood at 78 in
July of this year it was 306. just shy
of four times which means that to have
kept up with inflation your eight
hundred dollar gold ounce would have to
be valued at 3 200 but it isn't it's at
1900. not even close so not much of an
inflation hedge uh weight it gets worse
the standard and Poor 500 stock index
the end of January 80 was 115. uh as of
right now it's in the
4490 and that's right while the price of
gold was rising two and a half times the
S P 500 went up 39 times
not counting dividends which at the risk
of repeating oneself gold does not pay
with reinvested dividends and assuming
you paid taxes from another source 800
invested in the s p in January uh of
1980 left to compound would currently be
worth 95 000 not 1900 dollars
there's the difference in mutual funds
and gold
mic drop
you can't even argue with that I mean
the guy just laid it out so beautifully
boom in your face
phone
so I read somewhere that gold is
actually a pretty effective inflation
hedge over extremely long periods
perhaps a century or more not true
either by the way if you go back and
pull gold since the 1800s it has an
average annual of about 2.2 percent
or the S P has an average annual of
about 11.8 percent how is that an
inflation hedge it's not it's mythology
it's gold has the mysterious ability to
make people look like idiots
it really it's mysterious
I mean they make they say things they're
just blatantly not factual and believe
things that are blatantly not factual
because it is a Shiny Rock I do not
understand
but I'll tell you what from 1980 to
today
you could put 800 in and you'd have 95
000 or you could put 800 in gold and
you'd have nineteen hundred dollars
ouch
I don't know how anyone could just be
doing the math on that going well Dave I
just I sleep better at night now when I
got gold in case the economy got I got
1900 instead of 95 000. I'll help you
with your sleep
we've played this game because we've
played it out of what happens let's see
the every company goes to zero that's
what would have to happen for the stock
market to go to zero every company goes
bankrupt if the stock market had grown
from 800 to 1900s to 1980
oh the American economy would have
collapsed yeah
would have collapsed because that would
have been the the typical company is
losing money
that the average is that horrible I mean
for the stock market to be that anemic
the economy would have to be that anemic
and it would just be I mean I don't know
if our society would have survived if
the stock market had done the same rates
of return that gold had done wow think
about that yeah that's wild I mean you
would have had to make nothing on your I
mean geez like
yeah so these people are scared of the
stock market hey if this collapses I'll
have my gold bars and it'll somehow keep
its value in these dark times but
they've lost so much money that and it
hasn't even kept up with inflation that
I'm going I'll be way better off than
you just haven't been the tortoise over
here investing in the stock market for
30 40 years yeah
well it's about as dumb as the guy
called me up and said you know I got
four hundred thousand dollars I buried
it in coffee cans in my backyard that's
an inflation hedge Dave uh no it's paper
money and buried in the ground this is
not going to go well buddy
uh we're talking insects we're talking
dampness we're talking oh well I sealed
the car I don't care well even if you're
familiarated in the ground do you not
know those things rust
um and now what happens when you die
you're in relative your hillbilly
relatives are out there with their metal
detectors I would make that a reality
show
I'd watch that on HGTV that's about as
dumb why
you know and your 40 000 40 years later
having sit in the ground ain't worth
forty thousand dollars that was four
hundred thousand oh my gosh so I told
him you're losing forty thousand dollars
a year it's been ten years I said you've
lost you you know you've lost four
hundred thousand dollars what do you
mean I didn't I don't I didn't lose it I
know where it is no you lost what you
could have made another 400 000 in ten
years on this millions and meanwhile
they're sitting back there doing
absolutely nothing your 800 could have
become 95 but you put it in gold and it
became ninety five thousand and you put
it in Gold it became Nineteen Hundred
Nick you did a good job with this
article I don't know you personally I
hope we get to meet someday but your
analysis uh and your critical thinking
skills are dead on
um
yeah it is not proper to say that gold
or any other commodity is an investment
it is a speculation but it's not an
investment it reminds me of Investments
Investments have a an income that they
produce they have something going along
with them even real estate when you buy
it and it doesn't have an income
associated with it all you're looking
for is the increase in value now you're
speculating rather than investing um you
know that speculators lose money
investors make money well over the years
as you've been doing this Dave most
people are drawn to this out of fear or
which is usually not a great reason to
do anything financially fear agreed yeah
you're right yeah it it it's not I mean
right after I get afraid I get stupid
because I'm in freak out mode and my
critical thinking skills shut down I'm
in the middle of a trauma experience
when usually I saw a headline of some
guy yelling at them go buy gold it's all
coming down guys
go buy gold and silver you'll be okay
and uh doesn't work out like that and if
all goes down we're not going to be
looking for gold I'm not going to be
looking to trade Dave Ramsey for gold I
need food bullets shelter water ammo yep
bullets and ammo both both of those oh
Dave you're loading up over here George
I'm going to Dave's compound if it all
goes down so I'm okay you guys fend for
yourselves yeah so Nick Murray uh that
did this essay is quoting from the
August 7th online edition of The Wall
Street Journal the article that he was
uh picking apart was the titled when
markets get scary mom and pop buy gold
uh so not Mom and Pop That want to be
wealthy if you want to build wealth
typically what we find is people buy
real estate and they buy mutual funds
and they pay cash for their real estate
no debt these are the typical paths that
we find among millionaires we don't find
millionaires to say I got rich buying
gold
and now we know why because 800 in 1980
turned into 1900 today
and what is that 50 years or 40 years
later 45 years later
wow
in 45 years you doubled your money
barely
well don't dance in the street over that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
George Campbell Ramsey personality
co-host a smart money happy hour on the
Ramsay networks podcast
fabulously popular along with this
blasting off new YouTube channel George
Campbell with a K look it up he's my
co-host Today George is also going to be
working with the every dollar team and
hosting a free live virtual training on
budgeting tomorrow September 19th at 11
30 in the morning Central Time Georgia's
going to be good I love it and what I
love to do is show people what the
budget can do for you how it can create
that margin so that you can hit those
goals get out of debt and we're going to
walk you through it using our tool and
it's going to be a good time so join us
everydollar.com budgeting to sign up
it's completely free yeah here's the
deal John Maxwell says that a budget is
people telling their money what to do
instead of wondering where it went give
every dollar a name is what we say every
dollar in assignment that's how we name
the world's best budgeting app every
dollar it's completely free
for this training it's a zoom try
another Zoom train it's a webinar that
George is doing free live virtual
training George Campbell 11 30 a.m
September 19th tomorrow for most of you
check it out everydollar.com budgeting
we'll be doing a few more of these too
so be watching that particular site and
it'll tell you what's going on Dennis
and Shelby are in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage hey
guys welcome thank you thank you where
you guys from Washington State all right
welcome Tacoma Tacoma good welcome to
Nashville how much does it have you paid
325 000. all right and how long did that
take seven years seven years good and
your range of income during that time
start starting at 100 000 together and
then it dropped because of covid to
about 75. it has come back up to about
85. but now we're both retired oh wow
very good what were your careers good
um I work with uh armored car company
okay yeah she counts about 300 000 a day
okay all right I uh I have been driving
and uh what was your career before you
retired my career before I retired was a
post office worked at post office oh
great okay very cool good for y'all so
325 over seven years I'm guessing this
is the house
that's right you paid off your eyes yes
and a car weird people I love it
completely 100 Deadpool that's right
completely how long have you all been
married seven years oh wow okay so seven
years ago is when this started so we get
married we go okay knocking out the car
and knocking out the house tell us the
story what happened I was debt free
prior to this but when I met my wife I
said are you willing to go to uh
Financial Peace University and she said
absolutely so uh so we both went and she
got on board with me and uh two months
after we were married I said why don't
we see if we can pay off your credit
card
she she said I said okay and so uh in
her little savings account of five
dollars you got to start somewhere right
five dollars and I said if we pay off
your credit card I want you to make sure
to put the interest that you would have
been sending to them in the bank and
watch it grow so after about two months
she saw it grow and then we did the same
thing with her car
very good you're a great coach you got
her excited and motivated about this not
only that but she excited me because
every month she says we got a bill let's
get it paid so we just paid it well and
the fact that you were so willing Shelby
is amazing yeah you know honestly I wish
I had done this in my 20s it's just so
relieving yeah yeah now you don't have a
payment in the world anything how does
that feel it's amazing now we can give
more to and yes giving is just become
such a joy yeah wow was this a carrot
you dangled to say hey we're going to
retire once the house is paid off how
did that work basically my goal was to
make sure the house was paid off before
I retired and we got that done in April
wow and then and then you just call it
yeah good for y'all yeah well done very
well done all right now that you have
done it house and everything okay how
old are y'all
65. I'm 69 okay and so you started this
at 62 and 58 that's right okay so any of
you listening is it too late Dave no not
too late Dennis and Shelby did it and
they got a really bright future
financially I mean you got you can do
anything you want to do now uh so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
great
just use
take use the Snowball Effect is the
first thing that is the best way you
know all the tools that you taught us
the envelopes staying at home not eating
out just need versus want everything
eating out eating out is the most
detrimental thing you can do to your
budget in my estimation yeah we don't
eat out and this trip has been horrible
we've had to eat out every day
oh darn
it's not her cooking well I'll go along
with that okay I'm going home to dinner
tonight and it'll be sharing cooking so
there you go
so what's the house worth
house oh what is our house worth yeah uh
pushing uh 850 000. wow wow so you guys
are probably with Investments and
everything millionaires then yes we are
baby steps millionaires that's right way
to go you got it
seven years I like it what a great plan
you guys what a great plan who was
cheering you on as you're doing all this
I was cheering her on she was cheering
me on I don't know that we had anybody
else that's really on board you know
part of the family or anything
so yeah uh actually listening to your
show and and you guys are cheering us on
every day wow the surprising thing is
that we told everybody what you taught
us wow everybody that would listen well
and what did they say they were you know
they're always a little skeptical but
yeah we're trying to get our our kids to
do it everything yeah they'll get on
board eventually I like it yeah when the
student is ready the teacher appears hey
you know and you'll be there I just
praise God for the opportunity all right
way to go guys we're proud of you there
you go way to go hero
Millionaires and retired seven years
after being married in your 60s paid for
a house and everything this is what it's
about well done you have set yourself up
to enjoy this well done thank you we've
got uh the live and give box for you to
celebrate you being here that's the baby
steps Millionaire's book The Total Money
Makeover book and a Financial Peace
University membership you can use those
or give them away your choice whatever
you want to do for you to live or you to
give whatever you want to do people buy
that box all the time just for that to
use some of it and give some of it so
very cool congratulations you two thank
you
I love it I love it Dennis
Tacoma Washington 325 000 paid off house
and everything if they did that in seven
years seven years after they got married
in their 60s at 58 uh plus seven is
where we are today a hundred thousand
down to 75 down to 85 after retirement
setting pretty for the rest of their
lives excellent excellent work all right
Dennis and Shelby Tacoma Washington
count it down let Sarah debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you guys way to go
man
you know we get the uh 22 year olds in
here but getting the 65 and 67 year old
in here with a paid for house doing it
in the last seven years is very
impressive that's just as rewarding it's
such a great reminder not one we see
that often but it's just proof it can be
done yeah people in their 40s 50s 60s
they went hi Dave I made my mistakes
it's too late for me but maybe my kids
can do better and they went it's not too
late they're like hold my beer no I got
this we can do it retire with dignity if
we just sacrifice for seven years and
we're gonna have a great next 20 30
years of retirement I'll take that yeah
well they set up this next chapter of
their lives from 58 on from 62 or from
60 years or 62 on you say 69 or 67 I got
confused but either way yep 69 yeah so
um yeah 62 and 58 starting point wow and
you go okay we're gonna leave we're
gonna lean into this both of them are in
agreement and uh you could just see
there they are in sync well you guys are
listening and not watching you didn't
see it but you can see in their body
language that they're in sync they're
they're in agreement I'm such a joy and
peace I don't know there's been a study
done but I wonder if you did a study on
those who retire with no debt do they
live longer do they have a higher
quality of life my gut says yes
when you see that kind of piece now
stress registers in your body I mean you
know Financial stress it has to you know
yeah it has to have a medical effect and
just their their optimism yeah they're
hopeful I've never seen I've never seen
the study but maybe maybe we ought to
commission one there's an idea there we
go be like the millionaire study make
everybody mad this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
uh
our scripture of the day Proverbs 14 15
the simple believe anything but the
prudent give thought to their steps
Jack Canfield said I believe that people
make their own luck by great preparation
and good strategy Austin is in
Charleston West Virginia hi Austin
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for having me sure
recently my father passed away and uh oh
my left me four hundred thousand dollars
and I don't know what in the world would
do with it and I don't want to bury it
in the backyard and wait for inflation
you know I hear you I'm sorry what
happened to him
uh it was uh uh uncurable illness
how old was he
uh in his 50s oh my goodness how old are
you
I'm 29. okay all right how long ago was
this
uh
11 months
wow 400 grand
um well we always follow a process
around here because we truly have proven
that it's the shortest right way to
become wealthy the process we use is
called the baby steps
and so we would take the 400 000 and
begin to work up through those uh what
personal debts do you have not counting
your house
uh no death uh me and my wife both have
no student deaths we both owner Vehicles
okay do you own yeah
yes we own a home does it have a
mortgage
we do
um 220 000 left on the mortgage
um
but uh this is where I'm kind of in a
pickle with uh maybe that decision of
paying it towards the house is we have a
kind of a crazy rate for a mortgage and
it's 2.3 percent
and uh I'm curious or maybe you're the
thought of would that money be better
invested and make more money than the
money I would lose on paying it down on
the house yeah
um well the number when we studied 10
000 millionaires the number of them that
borrowed on their home
in order to invest the money and make
the spread in order to become wealthy
the number of them that did that was
well less than five percent ninety five
percent did not follow that path
thank you
that's real millionaires not somebody
with a theory on tick tock
um
and uh between myself I make 200 000 a
year sitting at home coding and my wife
is a pharmacist but she's currently
being a stay-at-home mom with our
newborn so
um I know there's money that come down
the line so
you know
what does that mean what does that mean
well I I know we're not going to be made
we're gonna we have the potential to
make a lot of money uh whenever she
starts working actually show your income
when she re-engages her career your
income's gonna be crazy yeah I got you
yes yeah it's great now it's great now
but it'll be crazy then yeah so what
would Dave and Sharon Ramsey do what
would George and Whitney Campbell do we
would pay off your house today we would
invest uh at the house payment plus a
thousand dollars a month in a separate
mutual fund just so you can see how fast
paid off house becomes a million dollars
if I did that when I paid mine off I
just I wanted to see how quick it
happened it was blindingly fast
I took my old house payment and added a
little bit to it rounded it up and you
know it's like 2 500 bucks or something
how fast that money alone became a how
that house payment became a million
dollars was crazy
and then and then of course you got in
addition to that you got another 180
000 or so that you can invest and with
no house payment at all and your house
payment plus some being invested dude
yeah the truth is the spread is just not
worth an ounce of your brain calorie you
have an incredible income you're about
to be completely debt free if you even
invest 20 25 of your income for the rest
of your life you're going to be
multi-multi-multi-millionaires
yeah
with freedom in the meantime with no
mortgage payment so what's your house
worth
um since we purchased it
um it is now worth 330
000 okay
all right and and so basically you got
four hundred thousand dollars
um with a paid for house and with a
hundred and seventy hundred and eighty
thousand in the account okay and you're
29 so at 36 that'll be worth 800 at 43
that'll be worth 1.6 this is if you add
nothing to it at 50 it'll be worth 3.2
at 57 it'll be worth 6.4
and at 64 it'll be worth 12.8 million
dollars
that's what four hundred thousand
dollars will be worth it'll double about
every seven years if it's invested
making around 10 or so and you've got it
in real estate you've got it in good
mutual funds that's where you should be
so if you don't do anything right after
this
as long as you avoid debt and not not
even invest more you're going to end up
with 10 million dollars at retirement
Jesus yeah that's how smart this is
and during all of that
you have zero Financial stress
yeah
some you know even before getting this
money you know we were my wife and I
were following your steps and you know
we started with building that emergency
fund once that was done starting oh
you're on the track then yeah yeah so
both of us have Roth IRAs and 401ks and
our emergency fund is beautiful and I
didn't even count that I didn't know you
had that
but everything is going great and with
our new with our new Sun that's another
thing um should I do anything with that
money for my son I know you are you're
Building Wealth
your dad did something for his son he
left him 400 Grand
that's very true it doesn't have to be
in your name
I I hate to go back to advisors but uh
you know they always say start like a
college fund the 529 but that's fine
nowadays well nowadays college is
getting more expensive and nowadays you
don't need a college degree to actually
make money so yeah you didn't in your
world but yeah better but yeah I I would
I would have some money set aside for uh
I would start putting some money into a
529 you don't have to over fund it
because you're going to have such a pile
of money you're gonna be able to just
write a check when they go to school but
having some of it in the 529 is not a
bad thing
and education is not a bad thing
knowledge is a good thing it's when you
do it knowledge in a stupid way that
it's a bad thing when you pay for the
famous school or you pay for a useless
degree that that's or you think a degree
is what makes you successful knowledge
is the currency and that's what we're
looking for yeah these kids are going to
school debt free and if you have a paid
for house and you're making 200 plus
they're going to be okay you could cash
flow the difference if they don't have
enough in their college account and so
that's the value of following these
principles yeah you're not even if your
wife wants to stay at home forever you
don't even blink you go man we don't
have a payment yeah go for it but I mean
if she's making if you guys are making
350 and you continue to invest and you
do what we just talked about and you
stay out of debt and you live reasonably
and generously you you should have
between 10 and 20 million dollars at 65
years old I mean there's no reason you
shouldn't have yeah the trick is wrong
shut up
still a good life oh my gosh really
and and um you know we will credit your
dad with a lot of that because that 400
000 mathematical jump start yeah you
will be one of the few millionaires that
became a millionaire because of
inheritance yeah
um you're probably almost there now but
uh but yeah that that's okay I don't
care where the money came from I care
how you use it and what your next steps
are that's the whole thing the hardest
part is ignoring all of his friends
family advisors who are going to tell
them to do something insane and stay on
social media in Tick Tock yeah I mean
we're on Tick Tock just because we got
disgusted with how bad it is over there
I'm trying to explain something good out
there yeah George is displacing the
toxicity the nuclear waste I'm only one
man but I'm a lot of man Dave
you are a serious tick tocker Dave
couldn't even hold a straight face well
I said I'm a lot of man I'm just
thinking I'm thinking about anybody on
Tick Tock saying that that's what I'm
thinking about that's fair it's hard to
call yourself a tick tocker and also say
I'm a lot of man yeah those things don't
go in the same sentence I'm just saying
uh
there's so many places I can go that's
one way to end it just not going to that
puts the sour the Ramsay show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]